you're looking very princess-like
tonight and my eyes say which brings me
very nicely to the first of a
conversation which is Maleficent what
everyone is so looking forward to it
what did you feel like when they gave
you the call to be a Disney Princess oh
that's that's a big moment that was
amazing yeah it's like sleeping beauty
she's like you know no way but you know
I had it was definitely a lot very
different from ginger and Rosa just
because they're complete opposites I
went from one to the other
whoops it was definitely much bigger a
lot of green screen and stuff like that
where ginger and Rosa was very intimate
you know we were all everyone on the
crew because it was it's an independent
film so everyone on the crew was there
because they wanted to be there you know
they really believed in the story and
wanted to make something special with
Sally so that was that was when you
moved from a lovely independent film
like ginger Rose we moved to kind of
those big greens green type things with
magnificent how is it as an actress did
you have a lot of green screen
experience before a little bit from
super 8 but not much because that was
sort of just for the monster part of it
but Maleficent definitely we were
creating like worlds like in the
background you and everyone the fun
thing about that is everything it's
everyone's imagining something different
you know do you really don't know what
it's gonna look like some and what was
it like filming with Angelina Jolie is a
terrible one in there yeah she is just
amazing I she's so cool oh my god so
cool and I found myself looking at her
and trying to like imitate her like the
way she's standing I was like let me
just try to be like you a little bit is
she truly scary is Maleficent oh she's
like elegant scary though like you she's
so scary but you just have to look at
her he's drawn to her she's amazing
you